on en a tellement parlé de ce troisième
lien Québec Rive-Sud
promesse électorale phare de la CAQ ça
allait se faire avec vous voyez des des
simulations transport en commun au
milieu on avait déjà commencé à modifier
un peu et réduire l'ampleur du projet
monsieur Legault disait
6,5 milliards c'est le budget qu'on
estime avec nous quelqu'un qui s'est
penché sur le troisième lien ingénieur
professeur à Polytechnique Bruno
mascotte bonsoir
bonsoir alors le projet initial
rappelez-nous là c'était transport en
commun au milieu ou enfin et deux voix
un tuyau qui allait dans un sens l'autre
dans l'autre
initialement c'était un gros tuyau il
est peut-être une année de sort après
l'anciend en deux pour des raisons de
faisabilité et il y avait des voies
réservées pour le transport en commun
des pour le transport
réglé donc voiture et camion et vous
donc
vous pour simplifier le pour résumer
l'état de la science vis-à-vis ce projet
là vous êtes de ceux qui avaient jamais
vraiment cru à ça
tout est faisable donc
la difficulté c'était justement de le
réaliser parce que le site est assez
difficile le tunnel est très long et
c'est surtout ces points de sortie
surtout le point de sortie du côté nord
comme votre infographie le montre le
point de sortie du côté nord qui sort
très loin du centre-ville donc qui qui
relie pas vraiment deux entrevues qui
relient l'autoroute 20 au sud
l'autoroute Laurentienne près du centre
Vidéotron au nord donc c'est et donc ça
a fait un tunnel très long qui répondait
pas nécessairement je pense aux besoins
de la ville de Québec entre pour pour le
transport donc ça revient deux banlieues
pas de centre-ville pour la partie
routière mais avec la chalandage
existant dans la région de Québec est-ce
que ce projet-là était nécessaire ce que
vous vous avez vu des chiffres qui vous
montrer que le projet est nécessaire
j'ai pas envie de chiffrer ça je pense
que les études vont sortir bientôt puis
j'ai entendu ce que les médias
rapportent mais je sais quand j'avais
fait la première étude en 2016
donc le trafic était justifié à peine
peut-être l'ajout d'un lien mais même à
ce moment-là c'était limite mais les
études ont été refait et je pense que le
trafic est réduit étant réduction
davantage depuis le pandémie donc
n'empêche que le
centre de Livi le centre de Québec sont
quand même excentrés par rapport au lien
donc on peut pas nier que
favoriser la connexion des deux
centres-villes c'est un besoin qui était
là pour les gens de Québec moi je pense
que c'est le besoin est là pour relier
le centre-ville le centre-ville d'où le
je pense le choix qui a été fait
ce qui est annoncé où il va être annoncé
officiellement bon mais justement alors
là jeudi le gouvernement va annoncer le
gouvernement le gouver qu'il recule sur
son le projet initial et qu'il n'y
aurait qu'un seul
tuyau pour reprendre l'expression pour
le transport en commun est-ce que ça
d'après vous ça tient davantage la route
je pense que oui
comme je vous ai dit centre-ville le
centre-ville ça peut si on regarde le
développement long terme de la grande
région de mon de Québec et puis relier
la rive sud et la rive nord favoriser le
transport collectif relié centre-ville
un centre-ville avec un transport
collectif un peu comme la ligne jaune
dans la région de Montréal je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui peut être très
bien pour un développement économique et
densification de la population aussi si
c'est fait une façon correcte pour donc
les deux les deux pôles qui sont le
Rive-Nord la Rive-Sud je pense et et je
pense que c'est un premier un bon un bon
pas dans la bonne c'est un pote dans la
bonne direction ça veut pas dire qu'on
n'aurait pas besoin d'un autre lien
routier éventuellement les deux ponts
commencent à vieillir le pompier la
porte de plus de 50 ans le pont de
Québec est plus de 100 ans donc
éventuellement peut-être que notre lien
routier sera requis mais ça laisserait
le temps de bien songer bien planifier
en fonction
besoin qui qu'on aura qu'on est
envisageable dans les prochaines années
ok mais sauf que si on construit un
tunnel avec une seule voix pour le
transport en commun on pourra pas après
ajouter des d'autres histoires pour que
les voitures puissent passer là il sera
pas au même endroit
si un quatrième lien on l'a appelé le
comme ça ou
il sera probablement dans un endroit
plus propice pour le transport routier
très bien on va on va finir le débat sur
le troisième avant de commencer le débat
je vais laisser ça mes enfants le débat
sur le quatrième Bruno masicotte
ingénieur professeur la Polytechnique de
Montréal merci beaucoup de nous avoir
parlé
bonne soirée